Good morning, John.
I've had a question sittin' up here for a little while and you know I got a lot of questions up there
frankly I'm kind of a question-y kind of a guy, but this question
has been sittin' up in the brain for YEARS, maybe like six or seven years now
so I wanted to get it out. Out of my head in the form of a song, and share it with all of you. I goes like this:
{strums guitar]
Oh, JK Rowling, what're you doing with your time?
Yeah, you're like givin' all your money to charity and I guess that sounds just fine,
but I'm wondering if you've got just a couple more jots.
Maybe, I dunno, you could crack a laptop.
Oh, do it as a favor to me, do it for the kids, or do it for charity.
Yeah, do it for the HPA (Harry Potter Alliance). Oh, I don't really care just to it today.
I know that the idea probably stresses you out.
I know that I would feel that way after making something so damn great.
For me it would be an inescapable cloud of doubt.
But don't let that fear get to you, this is clearly something you can do.
And the pressure from people like me, does it get a little old? Yeah, probably,
but hopefully you understand why I pry, so pick up your pen, Jo do it just give it a try.
So, oh, JK Rowling, what're you doin' with your time?
Givin' all your money to charity and I guess that sounds just fine,
but I'm wondering if you've got just a couple more jots.
Maybe, I dunno, you could crack a laptop.
Oh, do it as a favor to me, do it for the kids, or do it for charity.
Yeah, do it for the HPA. Oh, I don't really care just do it today.
I'm givin' you absolute creative freedom.
Maybe could write up a screenplay or a prequel musical for Broadway or collaborate on a comic with Joss Whedon.
Or a mini-series for the BBC. Any of that sounds good to me
I suggest you avoid cartoons or giving FOX a chance to cancel you,
and after considering this one pretty carefully, please don't make an MMORPG (massively multiplayer online role playing game).
'Cause that would totally destroy my productivity!
So, oh, JK Rowling, what're you doin' with your time?
Givin' all you money to charity and I guess that sounds just fine,
but I'm wonderin' if you got a couple more jots.
Maybe, I dunno, you could crack a laptop.
Oh, do it as a favor to me, do it for the kids, or do it for charity.
Yeah, do it for the HPA. Oh, I don't really care just do it. No, I don't really care just do it.
No, I don't really care just to it today!
What did I knock over?
Oh, it's just a bottle. Just a bottle. Just fell out of the garbage.
I was dancin' a little bit. And now I'm gonna get on a plane
to see John! [John:] Ayyyyyy! Glorious paternity leave!
[Hank:] This is pretty good. [John:] It's about as good as it gets.
[Hank:] Have you been doing this? Is this what you've been doing the whole time?
[John:] There's been some staying up all night as well. But not in like the fun teenage way.
Hank I'll see you on Friday.
[Hank:] You'll see me right now. [John:] 'I know I just haven't said it in a long time. I was feelin', I was feelin' it. Good morning Hank it's Tuesday!
*simultaneously* [John:} 'Yeah, I'm good. I still got it, I still got it! [Hank:] It's my video!
How's Alice? [John:] 'Aw, she's great. She's beautiful. We love her.
[Hank:] Good, you seem like pretty good parents, I'll be honest.
[John:] Haha, well, we try hard. I wanna thank Nerdfighteria for all their good wishes and we appreciate it.
Um, but yeah, we're just really enjoying being a family of four.
[Hank:] Wooh!
[John:] Yay!
[Hank:] John, [John:] Yes? [Hank:] I'll see you right now. [John:] Alright.
[Hank:] What just happened?
[John:] Henry just laughed at a joke for the first time.
[Hank:] What was he watching?
[John:] Annoying Orange.